what if I told you that there was an
event in the comics that was bigger than
the Infinity Gauntlet saga in the comics
and bigger than the Infinity Saga in the
MCU
well there is Avengers secret Wars
battle world how's it going everybody
it's Warren and Avengers secret Wars
battle world is coming and today's video
is about how the MCU is being set up for
the next Avengers in-game type level
event that is going to be even bigger
than Avengers in game and Kevin Feige
has even recently teased this in an
interview and the Russo brothers
actually teased this before as well so
for those of you who have been waiting
for avengers secret wars it is coming so
in this video I'll talk about how Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
has hinted that Avengers secret Wars is
going to be the next huge crossover
event and the MCU how the Russo brothers
will come back to direct the film and
how the x-men the Fantastic Four the
Avengers and the villains Doctor Doom
and Galactus will be in this as well
real quick don't forget to subscribe
when notifications turned on like this
video and comment below so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 the comic-con experience or
CC XP in Sao Paulo Brazil was only a
couple of weekends ago and although we
were expecting some big reveals and
there were rumored to be some big
reveals we walked away with only getting
some new footage for Black Widow and the
Eternals the Eternals footage was said
to be absolutely fantastic however the
whole fandom wanted something about
phase 5 however we weren't entirely
disappointed because immediately after
Marvel's panel at CC XP Kevin Feige
talked about the future of the MCU in an
interview and during this interview he
said that the MCS next big crossover
event is already underway and he even
mentioned that the multiverse which of
course is a huge part of Avengers secret
Wars of bottle world as the next
evolution of the MCU in this interview
he said that Marvel Studios is going to
focus on making the best individual
movies that they can make yes of course
everything in the MCU is interconnected
but they're going to focus on making
each individual movie the best they can
but then he said then yes it's always
fun to see them come together in a
master plan which is I promise you well
underway so he just confirmed that
big crossover event where all of these
other individual characters come
together is already well underway but he
did not stop there Kevin Feige went on
to confirm that the multiverse is the
future and it's actually been in
Marvel's plans to introduce the
multiverse for a very long time in the
interview he went on to say when we
first started the MCU it was all about
Tony Stark introduce people to Tony
Stark and that Iron Man armor then we
went on to teach people what as
Guardians were and learn about super
soldiers then bring them together in
Avengers I've always loved space movies
and I've always loved big intergalactic
tales which is why we did guardians and
the audience came with us so we could do
a movie like endgame I always wanted to
do time-travel which we finally got to
do an in-game the multiverse is the next
step in the evolution of the MCU and
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness is going to crack it open in
ways that will have repercussions so
Kevin Feige
the president of Marvel Studios
immediately after Marvel's panel at cc
XP was asked about the future of the MCU
and he said that the future and the
evolution of the MCU is the multiverse
and Avengers secret wars of battle world
is all about the multiverse to be more
specific it's about the multiverse
shattering during the Secret Wars event
the multiverse shatters and the remains
of the multiverse all come together to
create one world battle world on this
battle world Doctor Doom reigns as god
emperor doom and there are different
territories or domains on the earth that
belonged to different universes each
different domain or universe is
controlled by a baron which is a person
from that universe and in order to cross
into another universe or domain you have
to have permission from either God
Emperor Doom or the Baron of that
universe now there are a few different
battle world events and there are two
Secret Wars battle world events the
first one that happens in secret wars is
the Beyonder observes the main Marvel
Universe and he takes different villains
and heroes and transports them to a
different planet battle world and makes
them fight then the multiverse colliding
and the remains making up battle world
is in Secret Wars number two this is
where God Emperor Doom takes the power
of the Beyonder for himself now we're
probably going to get a combination
somewhat of the two of these but one
thing is for sure is that the multiverse
is eventually
going to shatter Kevin Feige has already
hinted at that and when it does we are
going to have just a ton of different
characters combining on one planet for
the biggest event of all time on
battleworld and the MCU we're going to
have the x-men the Fantastic Four the
New Avengers and not to mention the
villains and again this has seemingly
been the plan for a pretty long time now
it seems like Kevin Feige and Marvel
Studios had this planned for when they
would eventually get back the rights to
the x-men and the Fantastic Four and
this is proven years and years ago in a
deleted Ironman post-credit scene that
Kevin Feige has released where Nick Fury
says the word mutants and I'm about to
show you a deleted scene that has never
been seen by anyone before right now
thank you again so much and enjoy
[Music]
radioactive bug bites and assorted
mutants weren't enough I have to deal
with a spoiled brat who doesn't play
well with others and wants to keep all
his toys to himself there Liam Nick Fury
director of shield I'm here to talk to
you about the Avenger initiative Oh what
are we avenging whatever the hell we
want
so they recorded this scene in 2008 and
now we're almost in 2020 so Marvel has
been planning on the mutants or the
x-men and the Fantastic Four Doctor Doom
and Galactus to be in the MCU for some
time now and now that it's possible it's
time like Kevin Feige said in the
interview the evolution of the MCU has
begun and it seems like the Fantastic
Four Doctor Doom and Galactus aren't too
far away from entering the MCU it's been
rumored for some time now that the
Fantastic Four could be coming sooner
than later perhaps within the next few
years
and recently there's been a leak from
Charles Murphy stating that Doctor Doom
could be the main villain of black
panther - so the story arc for secret
wars battle world could start being set
up within the next couple of years now
executive producer Trent Tran has stated
that Marvel hopes to do the next
Avengers endgame type of event within
the next 10 years
probably not any sooner before but
definitely within another 10 years which
means that we can expect Avengers 5 but
before then it's not going to be a huge
crossover movie like Avengers endgame
but it's going to be more like the first
Avengers or Avengers age of Ultron and
this will establish the New Avengers
that way when they go into Avengers
secret wars battle world all of the
groups or teams will be established at
that point and it's going to be a lot
bigger than Avengers end game the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has already expanded
bigger than it has ever been before with
the introduction of the Disney Plus
series that are going to exist in the
MCU so just think about all of the
different characters and all of the
different teams that are going to have
available for Avengers secret Wars not
only are we going to have a new Avengers
team but we're also going to have
characters like the Eternals and then
Miss Marvel she-hulk Moon Knight not to
mention the Young Avengers that have
been rumored for some time now and of
course Deadpool there are already so
many characters that exist already in
the MCU or will come to exist in the MCU
with their Disney Plus Series
introductions or movie introductions but
then you add the Fantastic Four and then
you add the x-men this is why Avengers
secret Wars battle world is going to be
the biggest crossover event in history
it will have the Avengers the x-men and
the Fantastic Four coming together to
fight Doctor Doom and Galactus it's
pretty much all but confirmed that dr.
doom and Galactus are going to be the
two next big bad villains of the MCU
Galactus is going to be the cosmic
threat for our cosmic heroes and Doctor
Doom is going to be the earthly threat
for everybody on earth and these are two
of the strongest villains in Marvel
history which is why everybody is going
to have to come together to fight them
but having such a massive movie is going
to take the right people to direct the
film
luckily Marvel has the Russo brothers
and luckily the Russo brothers have
already name-dropped Secret Wars before
they've actually name-dropped it a few
times in a few different interviews in
an interview with The Daily Beast they
were asked about Secret Wars in which
they said it was one of the most
influential books this notion of heroes
coming together all those complex
personalities and villains coming
together we're guys who as storytellers
loved to portray villain characters as
emotionally complicated and partly
empathetic at times because we don't
leave that anyone is truly all good or
truly all bad we're all a mix of both
though heroes tend to lean more towards
good and villains tend to lean more
towards bad secret Wars just seems like
a prime opportunity to explore the
personalities of the characters and the
way that they interact with each other
and for alliances to be formed in odd
ways that the audience isn't expecting
it's just got a really high concept that
could be executed on a larger scale so
here you have the two directors of
Avengers endgame which was the biggest
crossover event of all time in the
highest-grossing film of all time
talking about Secret Wars and how it
could be bigger how it could be executed
on a larger scale
now the Russo brothers have said that
they're going to be taking a break from
directing with Marvel Studios but
luckily for us there is something that
they said could bring them back in an
interview with Collider colliders frosty
said that the x-men and the Fantastic
Four are coming to the MCU is there
anything that could bring them back to
direct and they said Secret Wars so the
movie that the Russo brothers would come
back to direct is Avengers secret Wars
and they've actually named drop secret
Wars and a few different interviews
aside from these so Kevin Feige has
recently named dropped the multiverse
and talked about a big crossover event
already in the works
Kevin Feige has already said that they
will be working with the Russo brothers
again in future Marvel films and the
Risa brothers have name-dropped
Avengers secret Wars several different
times talking about how they would love
to do the story arc and they've even
said that they would come back to direct
the film if Marvel made it well based
off of what everybody has already said
it seems like everything has kind of
already lined up an Avengers Secret Wars
is probably already in the works already
in fact according to Kevin Feige this
next huge big crossover vent is already
in the works and Avengers secret Wars
battle world is really the only way that
they could top Avengers endgame so the
president of Marvel Studios is hinting
at secret Wars and the directors of
Avengers endgame are hinting at Secret
Wars as well so it seems like the next
big crossover event is indeed going to
be Avengers secret Wars of battle world
this would be the ultimate movie even
bigger than a vein
endgame so let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
would you be excited to see Avengers
secret wars and do you think the rooster
brothers are the ones that should direct
it leave a comment down below don't
forget to like the video as well and
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you don't miss anything relating to
the MCU and so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
the winner gets to choose I'm picking a
new winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers don't forget to
click the link in the description down
below if you'd like a chance to win an
Infinity Gauntlet
and don't forget to use code cosmic at G
fuel comm for 30% off your G fuel as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof